how's it going rest my name is Pippa and
welcome to far I ask you Bros this week
is for suggestions on what to do on frog
and many many many of you were saying
draw my life and apparently it's a new
thing that all the cool kids do when I
haven't kept up with it it's always but
I tried and I failed
I don't have a lot of time to do with
brows so don't don't don't be hatin or
skate you can know you can't skate
anyway I'm going to show to you froze
and yeah there it is
hey how's it going Raz my name is
PewDiePie I'm going to draw my life for
you today my real name given by my mama
and Dada was Felix Felix is Latin and
means happy since the day I was born I
was living up to this name I was always
happy
I rarely cried and my favorite word at
the time was good
I'm still not sure about it it really
meant one day I went to kindergarten
with my hair up and wearing a skirt I
told everyone there I was a girl
needless to say I was fabulous
I spent most of my time in kindergarten
drawing teacher said I would grow up to
become an artist one day they were so
right Jaime look at this masterpiece but
I was actually drawing videogame
characters
Yoshi sonic donkey kong mario kirby what
you don't know Kirby videogames was my
favorite interest as a kid and has been
ever since our family didn't own a
console to play on because I played too
much but every time I was sick my mom
would rent a Super Nintendo for me
unfortunately I was sick a lot as a
child
quite a lot very sad I was also very
short as young and I wasn't allowed to
ride on the cool rides in the amusement
park but honestly I was too scared to
ride on them anyway I was still always
the happy kid who laughed and smiled a
lot but once the pubes hit I became more
quiet and introverted I was doing great
in school before but now I lost interest
in well everything I lost friends
connection with family I stopped being
creative it caused a lot of trouble for
me but despite all of it I had some of
my best memories playing video games
approaching the end of my teenage years
I started to break out on my bubble a
little bit I took a final attempt to fix
my grades in school and I wanted to
prove to myself that I wasn't really an
idiot one of my physics exams I scored
highest out of 200 students I got
accepted to my first choice of
university and everything seemed fine I
started to become more creative again
and made artwork in Photoshop it was
just for fun but I got the opportunity
to exhibit them at an art gallery and it
was a big success I spent the money that
I earned to buy a new computer so I
could work better in Photoshop but I
also bought it to do something I had
been wanting to make for years gaming
videos
I started uploading videos on YouTube
and I fell in love with the feedback
from my viewers every day I would wake
up excited to read the comments many
told me I would become big on YouTube
one day I never believed I actually had
it in me and many said the opposite as
well but it didn't really matter I was
just doing it for fun anyway
I eventually met this Italian girl
online she was stunningly beautiful and
we spent every single minute of our time
talking to you each other throughout the
entire summer and Emrys Madson at the
time I was working in a harbor and after
summer had ended I had earned enough
money to go visit her in Italy her
English wasn't the best and I couldn't
speak any Italian it was one of the
craziest things I have ever done in my
life but it's also one of the best
things I've done in my life once we met
we realized we were perfect for each
other
at the time my youtube wasn't big at all
and it was nothing I thought I could
make a living Adam I don't have any
money left so I had no idea how me and
Marcel would stay together march'd I
came to live with me in Sweden we stayed
in a small apartment and I made videos
from there it was nice we were happy my
channel on YouTube kept growing a lot I
still never really understood why the
first video I made I was even too shy to
speak but thanks to my fans I became
more and more comfortable and I started
opening it up to who I really was and
made the most important difference
because thanks to that I became the
happy guy that I had always been when I
was young I can finally proudly say I'm
living up to my name again Felix
all right I hope you enjoyed that um I
don't know I really don't know but
anyway thanks for staying awesome Russ
here's your breakfast bar demo activate